よろしくお願いします
二百六十八ページの二十七番目から始まります
パーリ語でパンニャッティ・ベーダと書いてますね
タトゥ・アヴァシェーサ・パンニャッティ・パナ・パンニャ・ティヤッタ・パンニャッティ・パンニャーパナ・ト・パンニャッティティ・ビーダ・ホーティと
で あの パンニャッティっていうのは言葉のこちらでない説明が入りますけど
アビダンマでは皆さんもご存知だと思いますけど
このショーグタイといって
この真理として見られるものを研究してきたんですね
いわゆるこの現象ですか
現象の哲学ではなくて
この実際にある真理の分析でやってきたんですね
で それ似ているものは我々にとっては科学の世界でも見えるんでしょうし
例えばまあ世の中で化学と物理学という二つありますね
そこでこの化学の化学の場合は
この まあ我々見ているような物質はそのまま見ているあるとは思っているわけじゃないんです
ただ 水といったっても
化学の場合は水という感じにはならないんですね
それは水素二つと酸素一つがつなげていることで
で その中でもつなぎ方によって水の種類いくつかあるんですね
で 水素二つに酸素も二つ入っちゃったら
まあほんのちょっと一つ増えただけで
私たちには全く別な種類が得られるでしょうし
それは日本語で何言うかわかりませんだけど
ハイドロゲン・ペロックスという英語で言いますけど
で まあそこでえーと何でしたっけ？この
まあそうやって例えば幻想というものが出てきて
で でも一般的な我々は幻想ということは全く知りませんね
ただ塩を 使っ使用して生活はしているんだけど
塩っていうのはナトリウムとかあのフローリンであることは全く関係もないし
そんなことは知りませんしね
で 私たちにとってはただの塩だけなんですね
で でも塩の味するものはまたたくさんなります
で 化学の世界では 例えばこのパパサルフェートですか
このあの青い色の あの
なんとか塩がありまして
あれ食べたら危ないんです
でも味が全く塩の味なんです
で であ ナトリウム入っているこのクロライドですか
それは食べますけど 例えばナトリウム入ってるサルフェートだったら
それはソーディウムサルフェート英語で言うんだけど
それも塩の味は塩味なんです
でも食べたら食べ物にならないんですね
で まあそういうことで
味だけで決めたっても困るんだと
まあことで とにかく化学の世界ではそうやってこの幻想やら
まあそうやって話をしているんですね
で それで物理学の場合は
そういう物質というよりは
物質の動きを様々な動きですか
それを研究しているんですね
動きと大きさとか形とかね
そうやってこの仏教において人は何ですかと
あるいは生命といえば何ですかと
世界といえば何ですかという場合は
まあそれはナーマとルーパという二つに分けて
ナーマっていうのは心の働きで
ルーパっていうのは物質的な働きで
それは厳密に分けて で
ナーマはまた 2つに分けて
心と心と心所に分けて
心という働きは 1つで心所は 52があるんだと
色にはまあ 28あると言いますけど
まあよく見ると 28もないですけど
それぐらいの身近な数少ないカテゴリーで説明していて
それからそちらの組み合わせはいろんなことをずっと説明してきたんですね
ですから それは将棋体の世界で一般的にはそこを本当にそうかということは一般の人にはわからないもんなんですね
ですから この科学の世界と同じなんで
そこはそれなりに勉強しなきゃ
本当にそうですかということはわからないです
そこでこのパンニャッティっていうのは
こういう意味なんですね
じゃあ私たちはここに田中さんがいるんだと言ったところで
それは嘘だと 田中さんという人は実際には存在しないんだと
あんた嘘を言うんじゃないんだと言って
世の中の常識を片っ端から壊していくんですかと
例えば建物があるということは
アビダンマから見れば全く違うんです
建物あるわけじゃないんです
そこにあるのは地水火風と
またそれに繋げてくる色
ワンナ ガンドラ ソージャという 4つの色がありましてね
だからパタヴィア アポティ
ロワーユ ワンナ ガンドラ
ソージャという 8種類の物質の働きだけであって
そこで目で見るとそちらにあるワンナという色ですか
それを認識しているだけですよ
だから建物を見てないんです
建物から建物持っているワンナという色
色というエネルギーだけ見ているんですよと
で というと なんか常識的にはその人と喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この 全部言葉なくなってしまいますかというとね
まあそこら辺で この常識的な人々の普通の概念の世界
まあということは まあ世の中の真理として認めているんです
ですから 例えばまあこの人は田中さんですよと言ったら
まあそれは世の中の常識で見ていることだから
そのレベルで田中さんですよということを認めるんです
で 故に田中さんという
もう何か実態があるか
真理があるという そこまではいかないんです
犬ですよと言ったら まあそうですよと
それでまあ世の中である動物に犬と呼ぶんです
で そうやってまあ人々が認めている言葉の世界
まあそこはそのレベルに限って認めているんです
それを取って 哲学作ったり真理語ったりするところは間違ってるんだということで
その哲学は否定しています
人間語ってる真理の世界はもう全部綺麗に捨てているんです
全部嘘やと でも一般的な
まあ俗世間で もう日常も街やら下町やらマーケットやら
そういうところで人々が使っている言葉は認める
そこで大学の教授がマーケットでキャベツ大根買って
料理して大学の教室で喋るものは全部嘘やと捨てる
簡単なもんなんです まあ他のレディーがまあ同じことで
例えばあの牧師さんが魚屋さんに行って
この魚美味しそうですねと言ったら
それはそうですよ じゃあ安いみたいだから
今日はね じゃあ買って食べようと
そこまではいいんです
それは真理ですと で 神様が人間のために大慈悲を持って作ったと言ったら
インチキ嘘を言うなと
この魚美味しいですよと言ったら
それはそうですよ そこまでは認める
あ 今日はなんか安いみたいな
今日はなんかすごく高いなとかね
そこまで認める だから仏教の言葉はどこで認めているかというと
やっぱり一般的な世界で人間使ってるぐらいは認めます
ですから 仏教ではこのもう神々の話やらね
そういういろいろへんてこりんなストーリーとかあるでしょうに
全然全くそのまま入ってるんです
例えばいろいろジャータカ物語を見ると
猿はしゃべるわ 猿が人間に説法するとかね
で 鹿がなんとかして 人間の王様より立派に自分の群れを守ると
そこでどういうことかというと
鹿が人間にも説法するんですよ
王だからもうあんたはこうこうやって自分の国民を守りなさいと
そういうストーリーは鹿がしゃべるかないかとかね
そこはもう全然考えてないんです
別に そこじゃなくて 一般の世界ではそれで通じるんです
マーケットのそういう普通の農民の人々にはそれだけで真理は通じますから
そのストーリーだけで
子供ちゃんとそこで道徳勉強する
例えばインドの道徳論というのはすべてストーリーで成り立ってるんです
論理学はないんです 全部ほとんど出てくるのはキツネですね
ジャッカルなんですけど
キツネと他の動物の間のいろんなからくりありまして
だからストーリーからストーリー
ストーリーからストーリー
だから子供たちにとってはこれは面白くて面白くて
そこでストーリーっていうのは枝分かれに行って
枝が分かれて分かれて分かれて分かれていくんだから
最後まで読まなきゃダメなんです
だからすごい上手い作り方なんです
だからと言って読むとつまらなくなるかというと
全然つまらなくならない
で このヒトパデシャというテキストがありまして
それは三宿の勉強のためにも学生さん読むテキストで
で かなり大きな本なんですけど
私は全部忘れちゃったんですけど
ストーリーはもう あれ五つに分けて大きなストーリーでもものすごい厚い本で
ライオンがいて ライオンが王様で
で そこにまあ ジャッカルですか
キツネですか で ズルすると
中に入る そこで王様はやっぱりライオンがある役割を果たす
で まあどうせ動物の王様だと思ってるんだからね
だからリーダー的な覚悟
で 狐はやっぱりいつでも狡い悪いことをする動物としてそこで現れる
そこで牛も出てくるんですね
で 牛はヒンドゥーの世界だからね
大変正直者で 忠実にこの人まあ
仕事をする人 だからこの正直者ととんでもないインチキ者と
まあ詐欺やってる人と
それからまあ社会でみんなまとめなくちゃいけないリーダーと
その三人なんですね で
そこでストーリーはそれだけで終わらない
ものすごい大きなストーリーで
で 最後にあのライオンがあの誰を殺すんですか？牛を殺しちゃうんです
だから これ読むためには
子供にいたっても三字熟語だから
これはまあ二 三年かかると思いますけど
もし原文で読める子供がいるとしたっても
まあ一ヶ月間でもかかるぐらい大きな本なんですけど
そこまでストーリー進んでいって
進んでいって 最後にライオンがあの牛を殺しちゃうというストーリーで
だからリーダーシップをいかにこのずるい人々に混乱させて
世界は多分もう悪い方向へ持っていくかと
あのシェイクスピアのストーリーの中でも
なんとかでしたっけ？同じこと
なんか似ているようなね
何かありますけど ですからこのそれでキツネは本当にこういうことを喋りますかとかね
そういう話は要りません
そんなまあ変な考え方
ただそこで何言ってるかと
まあそれだけであの十分なんですね
で あの最後の場面だけまあ覚えられて覚えてますけど
このすごい真面目に仕事をするんだから
やっぱり牛の方は信頼性があって
まあなかなかもう扱い方がいいんですね
そこでこのジャック このキツネ
ジャックのキツネさんがこの牛を食べたいんですね
肉食べる でも自分では殺せないんですね
体小さいんだから そこでこのライオンに殺してほしいんですね
でもライオンにとってはもうそれは一番信頼のある動物で
もう大臣だから 王様の
全部真面目に面倒見てくれて
だからそれはそうそうできない
殺すっていうことは そこで絶対ありえないことを
この心悪い人がいかにからくりをして実現するかというストーリーで
でもうそこで王様に言うんですね
この牛はもうみんなのもう信頼性があって
それでよく餌も食べて
体でっかくて 全ての動物の信頼性を持っているんだと
みんな信頼しているんだ
その上 あなたの体と比べてみて下さい
すごい でも王様はそんな話は聞かない
それにまあもう納得するためには
延々といろんなストーリーが出る
あのウサギさんの話もその中の一つなんですね
まあ寝ていたウサギさんが地球はもう振り返ってくるんではないかと驚いて逃げても逃げ回ったストーリーもその中に出てくる一つなんで
イソップの中とと同じなんですね
イソップに入ってるストーリーも
まあそこから向こう行ったんですけど
ぶつかります で とにかくこの王座ですか
王の立場をね 狙ってるんだと
企んでるんだということをまあどんどんどんどんどんどん説得させる
だから彼のすべてのいい得点を悪い方に解釈する
例えばあんたちょっと見てください
あの牛があっちこっち行くと
なんか他の動物といろいろこそこそこそしゃべってるんではないか
で 他の動物をみんなもうあの牛見たらすぐ来て
まあ牛と言わないけど
ちゃんと名前つけてますからね
その方が一番 何ていいかな
まあすごくかっこいい名前つけてある
みんなよく喋ったり それはその人の仕事を知っているんだから
他の動物いろんなことがあって
この王様に言うんじゃなくて
この大臣たちに言わなくちゃいけないんだからね
そこは喋ってるだけのことなんですね
彼も王様に代わってみんなの面倒をちゃんと仕事してるだけのことですけど
でも言うんで みんなあなたとは喋ることをしませんね
みんなもうあの牛とは随分親密じゃないかと
それはちょっとどうかなと思いますよと
そういう話をして 最後に言うのは
この牛にも同じことを言うんです
結局あなたは騙されてるだけ
あんたバカみたいに仕事するんだからね
仕事させてるだけですよ
あんた仕事できなくなったらもうクビになるんじゃなくて
まあ首は食べられますから
そんな王なんかはね 信じる必要はないんだと言って
牛はそれは認めないんですね
いやいや 偉大なる王様だからそういうことはありえないと
まあそこで牛にもいろんな話をして
信頼ちょっと問題作ってあげる
王にもいろんなこと言って問題作ってあげる
最後の場面というのは
あの お互いに違う話をつけて
で 王に言うんですね まああなたはもうもう殺す気になってるんだと
牛がもうすごい体がでかくて
で 今度挨拶に来ると見てくださいと
あいつはちゃんと頭下げてすねを
あの まあ牛は頭下げたら攻撃する体勢に見えちゃうんですね
あなたに攻撃しようとするんですよと
毎日同じことやっていたんだけど
毎日牛が王様に会ってちゃんと頭を下げて礼をしたみたいです
で 見てください そこでなんかライオンも王様だから
なんか手を上げてあの牛に挨拶するみたいです
ですから 牛にこう言ったんで
あんた行ったらあなたはもう殺す気になってるんだとライオンで
今度見てください あんたあんた見た途端
あいつはもう手を上げるんだと
で 同じことをライオンにも言ってる
そこであなたちょっと間違ったらもうライオンに襲われてもう食べられる
もう殺されるんだと ライオン同じこと言った
あんたちょっとでももうこの人私のことを心配していると思っちゃったら
もうあの爪でやられちゃいますよ
いくらライオンでも死んじゃいますよ
そこでみんなも信頼性ありますから
何のことなく王になってしまって
そこでその日はお互いにもう挨拶があったところで
どうせあの牛が頭を下げてきましたし
ライオンも毎日会うもうすごい一番信頼性ある番目の人だから
もう向こう挨拶するなりにしないなりにこちら挨拶するような
もう仲良しなんですね
手上げちゃったらいきなりお互いにもうぶつかったんですね
ぶつかってもうライオンが牛を殺しちゃう
というストーリー だからすごい
まあすごいストーリー
ストーリーっていいとは言えないのは
このこの小さなストーリーをもう二
三百ありますから なんかすごいまとめにくい
そういうことを言ったのは
やっぱりそれはこの科学者に文学者に言ったれば
くっだらないこといろんなこと言うんですね
それはもう古い古い話でね
現代小説ほどね 厳密に人間の心を分析していないんだとかね
ああだこうだとかね まあヨーロッパのこの何て言いますか
リテラル・クリティシズムというこの文学的なことをどのように批評するかという
そういう立場で見たりとかね
あんなものは全部何の意味もない嘘なんですね
あのストーリーは村の村で子供たちに言ってみてください
その子供たちはしっかりした人格作っちゃうんです
生き方 世の中の人間の生き方はきちんとほんのちょっとのストーリーで勉強しちゃうんですね
だから あのヒットドゥレーサに出てくるストーリーはずっと人類やってることなんですね
正直者はいつでも最終的には負けてしまう
いつでも汚い心でズルいことをやっている人々は
いつでももうズルいことをやっても世界を支配している
そこで政治家やら王様はいつでもバカもんで
人を言うことをそのままで聞いて
もうとんでもないバカもんたちなんですね
自分の仕事をしっかりしない
言って殺したところで
王様はものすごく悲しくなっちゃう
ああ まずいことをしましたと
もう遅いんですね ですから
そういうこの複雑な人間の生き方
子供たちに簡単に教えているんです
だから私も今はいい加減なことを言うかもしれません
だけど 現代のこの倫理学やら大学で教えているあの何にも役に立ってないでしょ
一人の人間も立派な人間に作ってないでしょう
みんな社会に入った途端
もう驚いて驚いてどうしようかどうしようかと
だから賄賂を遅くするようにはずれるか
バカみたく仕事をして最終的にクビになるかと
どっちかになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから世の中をうまくこの生きる方法がわからない
正しく道徳を守って生きてられる方法わからなくなっちゃうんです
ですから このというわけで
仏教ではこの街で人々が使っている言葉とかね
田舎の人々が使っている言葉とか
そういうのはそのまま認めている
それについていちいちいちいち喋っているこの哲学的なものだけは
まあその何のこともなくまとめてごみしてるだけ
だから経典読んでもそれはよくわかりやすいと思います
哲学者が聞いて質問したりすると
ものすごい厳密にそれは分けて分別して
一つ一つ片っ端から壊して
あの人は何もない人にしてしまっちゃう
そこで何もことも知らない人が来て
まあ私は大変こういうこういうこと言ったら
何のことなくその人の言葉を借りて教えてあげる
全然もう反論しようとはしないんですね
一般の人が来たら ですから
この言葉の世界についても
そういうわけで 仏教ではかなりあのー
きちんとした立場を取っているんです
そこら辺の説明ですね
アビダンマでこのパンニャッティというパンニャッティっていうのは世の中に決めているということ
で このパーリ語 日本語でこの「せせっす」という言葉使ってますけど
せせっすとはどういう意味ですかね
パンニャッティっていう場合は
このパンニャッティというのはいろいろ意味があって
この知るために あの知るためにするちょっとした工夫というような意味なんですね
パンニャッティっていうのは
そういう意味があります
それから あの 世の あの
世の中の一般的な使い方という
いわゆる常識というものなんですね
常識と言った途端 常識がちょっと間違ってはいけません
あの 常識だから真理というわけじゃないんです
だから私たちはそれは常識だよっていうのは
それはもう真理ですよという意味になっているんですけど
英語で言ったってCommon Senseだから Common
Senseというのは
だからCommon Senseだからといって真理ですよと
だからその通りだということはないんですけど Common
Senseだからみんな知ってるんだよと
みんなそこをそういうふうに理解しているんだよということですね
それ以外は何もないんです
で 他のことはこんな難しいことではないんだから
あの 読めばわかると思います
そこでパンニャッティは
あの 何て言いますか パンニャーピアッタ
パンニャーアパナと という二つに分けてあって
せせっす せられる それからせせっすさせると
そこでそれまた二つアッタパンニャッティ
サッダパンニャッティになっていますね
ここは全くわからないように書いてますから
他の別な説明ありますけど
わかりやすい そこはないみたい
もっと明確に分析したところが
我々が勉強した時はもっとすごい明確に分析して勉強した覚えがありますけど
このテキストではないね
あるいは最初に出た可能性はあります
そういうこと そういうこと
テキストではないんです
で そんなに難しいを考えなくても
これ大体読めばわかると言いますけど
別に難しいを考えなくてもいいんです
例えば山とかね 家とかいう場合は
そのアビダンマから見ればチースイカーフーなんですね
だからチースイカーフーのどの
は事実であって そこはどのようにあるかということを見て
これは山であって家ではありませんと
これは家であって山ではないんだと
これはチースイカーフーですよ
山を見てチースイカーフーですよと言ったら
もうなんか喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
知ること 喋ることできなくなっちゃうんです
だから あるチースイカーフーを見て山という
あるチースイカーフーを見て家という
あるチースイカーフーを見て車という
そこで実際に山と家はどのように違いますかというと
どのように違いますかね
そこでこの真理の立場から差が見えませんね
本当は そこで我々の世俗の世界ではいくらでも差が言えるんだけど
例えば山っていうのは住むところではない
家っていうのは人は住むところでしょうと
それは人は住むということは
もう真理の世界の話ではないんです
それはもう科学的な何とか何とかっていうところ立場ではないんですね
だから一応チースイカーフーなんですけど
チースイカーフー 量やら積み重ねてる空間はどのように取っているかとかね
ただそれだけ考えていいんですね
そこでサンバーラ・サンニヴェーサカーラン・ウパーダーヤ・デーハ・ガタ・サカタ・アディカ
そこでこの家 車などはこのチースイカーフーをまとめて
いろいろチースイカーフーを私たちがいろんな方法でまとめて
いろんなことを言うんですね
例えば紙を折って鶴を折ったら鶴と言うんだから
別に何かしたわけじゃなくて
単なる 1枚の紙を 打っただけなんですね
で 売ることによって この紙の小さい花粉がある場所が変わるだけ
それだけでこれは紙の鶴だというんですね
だから場所が変わるとかね
まあそれぐらいのことで
それから男です 女ですとかね
人ですと犬ですという場合は
そちらにあるのは五蘊なんですね
色受想行識という五蘊だけですね
犬でも男でも女でも誰でも名前で言ったって田中さんとか何々さんといっても
そこにあるのは色受想行識というその五蘊だけなんですね
その五蘊に我々は別々にラベリングをして名前をつけて
それを理解する 人間です
動物ですと言った途端
人間も五蘊であって動物も五蘊なんです
そこで私たちはそれを知るために何か言葉を使う
実際にあるのは色受想行識という 5つだけなんです
それから東ですと西ですと言うでしょう
どうやって東西と成り立つんですかね
本当は東も西もあるわけないんです
そんなのはないんですけど
まあただ人間から見れば
日が昇る方向を見て東というし
進む方向を見て西という
それで それに従って東の方は右側だったら前の方はもう北になっちゃうし
後ろの方向は南になっちゃうし
中国の漢字の意味はわかりませんだけどね
やっぱりインド的に見ればね
やっぱり 東はプッダプーラバーガとかブッダとか言って
この現れるというfirstという言葉を使っているんですね
初めという そういう意味で使っているんですね
だから初めという方法と終わりという方向アッラバーガですね
それはもう西ですね そういうやって言葉つけて
そこでどうせ初めの方がもう右側が一番もういい方向に
体の場合はね 右の方が大変
褒めている方向 褒められている方向だから
もう初めの方に右手を入れたところで自分の前という意味で北というウッタラっていうのは前っていう意味なんです
南っていうのは後ろっていう意味なんです
で そこで東西南北は成り立つでしょうし
だからインドの言葉はそこをよく見るとちゃんと分かりやすい
どのようにできたかという
できたかということ  [背景の音楽]